coronary angioplasty also called
percutaneous transluminal coronary
angioplasty or balloon angioplasty is
designed to restore the flow of blood
through coronary arteries narrowed or
clogged by a thorough Scott ik plaques
or blood clots
when you arrive at the hospital an
intravenous line will be started you
will be placed on a heart monitor and
you will be given an oral or intravenous
sedative to help you relax
most coronary angioplasty procedures
lasts between 30 minutes and 3 hours the
doctor numbs the skin in your groin area
and inserts a needle into your femoral
artery once the needle is placed a guide
wire is passed through the needle and
gently guided through the arterial
system to the heart the needle will be
withdrawn and exchanged for a small
flexible tube called a sheath permitting
access to your femoral artery at this
point you will be given a blood thinner
to reduce the risk of blood clots next a
soft flexible catheter is slipped over
the wire and threaded up to the heart
the procedure is monitored using a
continuous x-ray imaging device called a
fluoroscope you may feel pressure as the
wire and sheath are inserted through the
groin and pushed through the artery but
you will not feel their movement inside
your arteries at this point your doctor
will remove the guide wire position the
tip of the catheter just inside the
coronary artery to be treated and inject
a special dye the dye allows the
fluoroscope to take x-ray images called
angiograms of the arteries interior any
blockages will be clearly identified as
the arteries fill with the dye you may
feel flushed or slightly nauseated when
the dye is injected once the blockage is
identified your doctor will insert a
flexible guide wire into the artery and
advance a balloon tipped catheter over
this wire and into position at the site
of the blockage rapid inflation and
deflation of the small balloon pushes
the vessel wall out re-establishing
blood flow through the artery you may
feel some chest pain while this is
happening the same procedure is repeated
for each blockage being treated
afterwards your doctor will withdraw the
deflated balloon and catheter from your
arteries some patients will receive a
coronary stent which is a small tube
made of wire mesh designed to prop open
the artery once it has been treated a
collapsed stent is placed over the
deflated balloon as its
moved into position when the balloon is
inflated the stent expands and locks
into place
after the balloon catheter withdrawn the
stent remains behind to hold the artery
open permanently
after your procedure a pressure bandage
will be applied over the femoral artery
to prevent bleeding you will need to lie
on your back for several hours during
which time you will be checked
periodically for any signs of bleeding
or chest pain you may either be
discharged home on the same day or after
an overnight stay in the hospital